mobilité durable mobilité propre ce n'est
pas seulement quelque chose pour les pays occidentaux riches
c'est déjà au moins aussi
viable sinon plus viable dans le
sud global que
dans le nord global [
Musique]
je ne sais pas
[Musique] [
Musique]
rwanda
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
sarah
étranger
ok
merci
[Musique] [
Musique]
ici où ces motos taxis
travaillent 12 heures par jour
parcourant 150 kilomètres par jour en moyenne
ils dépensent plus d'argent chaque année en carburant
qu'en coût  d'une nouvelle moto, donc
environ 1500 euros, ils passeront un an à
acheter du carburant, ce qui représente bien plus d'argent qu'ils n'en
rapportent
à leurs familles.
L'afrique n'est pas un grand contributeur au
changement climatique,
en particulier dans le
secteur des transports, mais d'un autre côté.  main dans le monde alors que
nous pensons à 2050, un quart de
toutes les personnes sur terre étant ici en
afrique
et ayant besoin de se déplacer et de devenir
plus riches, il est important de mettre
ces systèmes en place dès le début
et il n'est pas nécessaire d'utiliser ce vieux
combustible fossile-  basé sur un
système sale et sale, le monde ne peut pas se permettre que
vous